there is nothing free or fair about this
vote
people in occupied parts of Ukraine cast
ballots in a referendum to join Russia
widely dismissed as a sham
votes are now being counted but with
zero suspense as the outcome is expected
to be yes
it would pave the way for Vladimir Putin
bogusly to declare for occupied
Ukrainian regions as Russian
the governor of one of the regions said
this could raise the risk of Moscow
using nuclear weapons against Ukrainian
troops fighting to regain their land
[Music]
he had a message for all those mobilized
to fight in Ukraine is
foreign
the city of kramatosk is a symbol of
Russia's limitations
emptied out by the war but still fully
under Ukrainian control it lies in the
heart of Don yet's region a core Target
of the phony referendums
yet residents here still pay the price
this couple tidy away after a rocket
strike
they don't seem bothered about Russia's
land grab
um
more misery at an evacuation point in a
next-door region for those fleeing areas
occupied by Russia
we meet families who've escaped from
parts of zaparisia as well as Herson
region both also targeted by Russia's
referendums
this mother fled her Village before
voting she didn't believe it would be
fair
um
displaced and distressed but these are
the lucky ones they've at least escaped
the distorted reality of Life under
Russian occupation
debraham Sky News Southeastern Ukraine